thank you
[Music]
all right y'all we're talking about a
serious thing today oh yes okay we are
talking today about leukemia G oh
wedgies have you guys experienced the
wedgie dude never ever every type
every type have you experienced the
atomic wedgie was that Atomic is that
one who goes over your head it is how do
you know that
well you've never received the wedgie
your whole life
is this a setup
hey come here Nick if you guys can try
can we just do it can you let us do it
just so you can be have your food I have
hemorrhoids bro you're gonna tear me not
after this you're somebody who's gonna
fix my hemorrhoids no it'll just push
them back in
hey I think you should try it no dude
you think why you think it's Ryan's
always made of good ideas I think you
should try it it's hard to move on the
conversation knowing you've never
experienced that has can Nick come to
this side of the room now dude you're
not gonna put it away
[Laughter]
are you wearing like a weird underwear
huh
yeah
oh laundry day are you wearing kinky
underwears that way nah dude is it Lacy
would I say it's edible I think yeah
[Laughter]
it's not weird well uh just imagine what
it's like and you're probably right it's
I'd imagine it would hurt your your
balls a little bit
when was the last time when was last
time you've been wedgied Anthony Lee
don't deflect that's not deflecting it's
a question
you deflected my other question how do
you know what an atomic wedgie is I just
I honestly just guessed I just figured
I've seen people do it over their head
and I was like that seems pretty bad
seems pretty it seems like yeah it seems
like it's the worst case scenario I have
to do that it's really difficult without
the underwear ripping you need some
stretchy underwears yeah you made it red
dude yeah all the time today we had it
we you know in my first viewer crew that
was like a tradition that if you like
actually no reason we would just grab
this one dude and just wedgie him to the
point where his underworld was broke is
he still a part of the crew yeah that's
called bullying yeah he's a doctor now
he's like dude we had this tradition
actually just to one guy yeah where
everybody would do it to him he's a he's
a doctor of Chiropractic now no way yeah
great guy great dude lots of underwear
of his got ruined is is his spinal
jacked up from the [__] wedgies did
he stop wearing shiny writing he never
had tighty whites he had those nasty
great it always works the best with
tighty whities let's see if there's a
streak on it oh that's embarrassing to
get wedgied and you have dirty underwear
it is it is wait why are we talking
about wedge because on December 21st
2013 Marine Corps veteran Brad Lee Davis
that's a cool name gave his stepfather
stepfather 58 year old Denver Lee
Sinclair in atomic wedgie and he killed
him I killed him yeah what what killed
him oh no wait but what's an atomic
wedgie where you pull the undergarments
elastic band all the way up over the
head that's what my brother used to do
and you survived and you are a survivor
yeah do you think he's like a tall guy
with the underwear like or he was a
short guy what short torso what what
happened maybe maybe it asphyxiated him
on the other way because uh for kids an
atomic wedgie would like work for kids
but if you're in a grown adult how does
the underwear even get that far that's
what I'm saying it's like the real
practicality of it is most underwear
rips by the upper back Point yeah yeah
they're proven by his uh many
experimentations so maybe his balls got
tucked so far back that it exploded or
struck a nerve or and that's death wow
dude you die from atomic wedgie bro
what's going on or did it go all the way
and then it went here and then it
suffocated him that's what I'm thinking
did he have a heart attack from the
embarrassment
also I have a hard time seeing that like
if underwear is that flexible to get
this far it's probably thin enough that
you can breathe through it or flexible
enough that you could just pull it off
right you just be like wearing a Batman
mask or so strong that once it got here
his spine went like that and it just
that's yeah what if it was silk yeah or
it was probably a g-string and that's
why it goes all the way around and then
it oh because I would know is it like is
that why you don't recommend receiving a
wedgie today
that's the reason why dude you guys were
about to kill nick man I just you
[__] trying to give me a wedgie dude
another alternative when it goes over
him he's like
it's not even the wedgie all the way out
the front door yeah or and then a snake
comes and it bites the ball
by wedgie so are we close
very close but before we you know get
the final reveal the Cobra didn't bite
his dick I mean let me continue to yeah
give us more details cobras wait for
situations like back again all right
okay now
this particular incident led to two
things number one a first degree murder
charge for Davis yeah and then first
degree premeditated
a study by the National Institute of
Health their first ever study on wedgies
to figure out how the hell this was a
news day over there huh
all right so that happened
Davis told the police he'd never
intended to kill his stepfather okay the
man was just trying to embarrass him and
an atomic wedgie was just the most
embarrassing who intends to like you
guys are trying to give me one I'm not a
first degree fence
should be second though authorities at
the time said the two men were spending
the night in Denver uh in Denver's not
Denver Colorado but like the guy's name
is Denver in his trailer while Davis's
mother was recovering from hip surgery
at the local hospital because he gave
her a wedgie and [__] her uh no that
was the snake
um the two men intended to go visit her
early the next morning but they stayed
up late talking and then eventually
Sinclair began insulting Davis's mother
yo mama jokes that's good the Marine
corpsville Mama's hip is so broken
and we interrupt this video to get the
best Yo Mama jokes
and we're back so
the Marine Corps veteran told his
stepfather that he was a bully and
things turned physical according to
reports David said his stepfather got up
and tried to punch him but the trained
Marine easily overcame a stepfather to
tackle leaving the older man on the
floor that's when Davis decided to add
insult to injury with a wedgie
so that's apparently the
the more practical speculation so did
the paramedics show up with the
underwear over his head while Sinclair
was still on the ground Davis pulled up
the old man's underwear
traditional wedgie he then went the
extra mile pulling the elastic band of
the underwear over the man's head he
then took a photo of this incident
somehow however the band made its way
around Sinclair's neck cutting off his
Air Supply and effectively strangling
him yeah the G string theory is correct
when police arrived at the scene
Sinclair was dead and Davis was taken
into custody the prosecution believed
that things were more than they seemed
believing some of Sinclair's wounds
before the wedgie would have killed him
anyway oh damn that's a
[__] that's a big detail Davis with
first degree murder and the media
labeled him the atomic wedgie killer he
would have been dead anyway because it
was so far up his ass
yeah
do you think he did the wedgie as a
alibi he's like oh they'll say that it
was an accidental death I already killed
his [__] he went cheated himself
if he's beat worse that would die
without the wedgie so he got beat up
from
he died from getting counter punched
basically that's what the prosecutors
are are basically saying they they went
on to allege that Davis doctored the
crime scene before investigators arrived
making it look like the wedgie killed
him and the two had come to blows during
a family argument
plead not guilty because he was acting
in self-defense put the evidence against
him was too strong this guy this guy did
the world's first friendship fatality
they weren't definitely friends huh in
the end Davis pled guilty for a lesser
charge first degree manslaughter which
carried a four-year prison sentence but
the judge presiding over his sentence
believed he'd acted with much more
malice than four years would Warren and
threw the book at him 2015 Davis was
sentenced to 30 years
damn that judge got wedgie that's okay
before and it didn't kill me so I know
Survivor I Know That You're a murderer
he's a Survivor like you dude
I survived
hey another what's another one what's
the other one when you get a wedgie and
then your legs get hog tied to the back
and then they tie the underwear uh have
you done have you heard of that one that
sounds like the atomic wedding that's
the Corpus Christi yeah
that was a pretty rough thing
are you a survivor of that as well yeah
I haven't gotten wedgied like that but
I've gotten pants before
that's the difference you just laughed
at him dude because because I remind me
of the story where his death where his
brother passed his dad at a funeral
what that was you no I didn't do it it
was your parents that was as fast yeah
yeah yeah remember that stupid yeah yeah
yeah tell us tell the story even told me
and Joe this story on a podcast and we
were laughing for like 15 minutes
straight bro you want me to retell it
retell it yeah because I've never heard
it so my grandma passed away rest in
peace grandma on my dad's side and she
lives in Vietnam or lived in Vietnam and
so there was a funeral over there and so
they do it like really different they
have like a whole week or something like
that where you know you just
uh spending time with the thing but so
it was at the end it ends outside for
like three days and doesn't eat and [__]
like that so yeah so like people have
been grieving and like celebrating her
death for like a whole week it's the
last day and the last thing they did was
like go to her room where she used to
stay and like do some prayer with like
incense and stuff there's like a viewing
and and
um everybody's just dressed in normal
clothing but my dad and I think a few of
uh my uncles were wearing these white
garments over that all white yeah and so
at the end of it it was over and my dad
starts taking it off and then like
everybody's still in the room and my
brother goes up to my dad and pulls his
pants down
and my me and my mom look at each other
and we're like yo like you know how
you're like you're not supposed to laugh
at a funeral but like I had to like walk
out of the room I was like oh my god
dude
he's like in his 20s at the time like he
was fully grown this was only in like 20
uh 2012. is this his thing that he does
what no he was just his thing I I don't
know what caused him to just go up to my
dad in front of everybody and just go
like this and everybody was just like
quiet except for me and my mom we were
like what the [__] Listen People deal
with grief differently what did your
brother say right after that he was just
smiling he was like what did your dad do
right after that he ignored it because
he he was just like
bloodier
yeah he did but he wasn't crying at that
moment oh [__] yeah his mom just died
and he's like pants around his ankles
yeah his own mom just died
by his 20-something year old son who's a
[__] kid or something yeah dude it
wasn't like all his whole pants it was
just like the pants outside the pants so
it still looked like it though so it's
just a white garment yeah yeah but it's
still like a funeral clothing yeah and
he just no no don't ruin the story in my
head
yeah yeah that was what was fun here
foreign